as we adjust to this new reality some
members of our families have been big
fans of it pretty much since day one our
pets especially dogs are getting more
face time with their humans than they
have possibly ever and what do we get
back well all that unconditional love at
least from the dogs cats of course give
it when they feel like it a lot of
people have decided this is the
opportune time to get a new pet and our
mic'd relay is one of them check out
this handsome guy no no no look down the
other handsome guy that's Magnus the Pug
a four month old memory-making a
pandemic puppy pugs if you didn't know
really liked to zoom around and the cure
to the zoomies we've since learned is a
collar and leash his stubbornness has
been remarkable trying to go for a
morning walk as opposed to but
entertaining in a way that it's exactly
what my family needed after being thrust
into isolation for my little girl this
pandemic puppy has been everything
[Music]
remember the early days of isolation and
her feelings were all over the place
scared sad frustrated and bored in
Calgary Chelsea Simpson found herself at
home with little to do and then she
remembered a conversation with her dad
basically my dad told me about a year
ago if I could keep a plant alive for a
year he'd get me a puppy well the plant
lived so now she has beans a mini poodle
she's slightly obsessed with he's very
precious with limited human interaction
beans much like Magnus has filled a void
and not just in her life it should come
as no surprise beans has an instagram
page which is far more popular than she
ever dreamed it would be pretty
interested in his day-to-day activities
so I think people are just kind of bored
but it's been fun like my friends
obviously love watching him on social
media if there's one thing people
initially had a lot of it was time
certain things became scarce toilet
paper and cleaning products the Nintendo
switch video game system and dogs
the Toronto Humane Society placed 71
dogs into foster homes in February and
then 141 in March scammers took note
putting up fake ads for puppies the
anti-fraud centre saw almost as many
cases in the first four months of 2020
as it did all of last year and young
Kendrick rad Moore had his sights set on
a Havanese puppy he wants to name speedy
except the breeder his family chose had
already sold the first two litters of
the year so we're actually not to August
so while they know the puppy is coming
they also have to wait which isn't going
to be easy even for a six-year-old with
so much compassion for animals he asked
his friends to donate to a zoo or
sanctuary in lieu of birthday presents I
know just waiting well we're doing a lot
of that
you learn a lot about this dog before we
get the dog
yeah it shouldn't be much of a surprise
to anyone that puppies have become the
pandemic super pet how do we know this
science studies have shown that dogs
have the innate ability to reduce stress
in our lives and they know when to step
in because they're able to read our
facial expressions so in essence every
dog has the potential to be paw patrol
but dogs also take a commitment level
not everyone can offer which is why the
yips pandemic puppy is actually a pair
of chickens they've rented until the
fall a cocoa and vanilla offer up a
fresh egg and then spend the day running
around doing chicken things before going
back to their coop the spectacle of it
all has become surprisingly therapeutic
for the cooped up kids it was a total
whim I guess I had this urge to have
livestock but I figured this is the only
summer we're gonna be here the entirety
of it we're not traveling and I needed
something to get them off iPads saying
goodbye in the fall to cocoa the stupid
in vanilla the stubborn will be hard
just as a return to normalcy will be on
the dogs who have gotten used to having
their new best friends around all day
long
let's go but right now I'd better go
walk the dog again come on let's go
[Music]